(audience applauding)
- And we are back
with the wonderful Nicole Richie.
(audience applauding and cheering)
And by the way, it's always
so exciting in business
when you can keep your promises.
That's what Nan, my partner,
and the love of my life,
other than my daughters,
she would always say, keep your promises.
If people allow you to use their money,
and take a chance on you in
business, keep your promises.
And you're crushing it
for Quibi right now,
and it's so great because then, you know,
it's nice when it works for everybody,
and you get to keep your
job, and they're thrilled.
It's like, then it's good business
as well as a wonderful
creative opportunity.
- Yeah.
Obviously, just like you were saying,
sometimes you have to
create your own roles.
I think whatever you're
doing, whether it's designing,
or acting, you want to be in a TV show,
or you want to read a book,
it's like, actually a lot of that stuff
comes from the person
saying to themselves,
I wish there was a story about this,
or, aw, I wish, even with
me with House of Harlow,
I used to be like, I wish I
had like, a kimono, you know?
You just think about
things that you would want
that don't exist, and you're like,
well, I guess then I will
go and create it myself,
or write it myself, you know?
And I think to have those moments,
they're few and far between,
so when you have that creative spark,
it's important to just run
after it, take advantage of it.
- I think that is excellent advice,
because you're an amazing brander,
and then this show has
proven to be successful
for you and Quibi, and
everybody's loving it.
And I think that's a good thing,
to sort of strike while the iron is hot,
grab that inspiration when you have it.
You always think in a dream
you're gonna remember it in the morning-
- [Nicole] Then you don't.
- And sometimes you don't.
So I'm equating it to that metaphor.
Go after it and catch those
butterflies in your net.
- I remember you saying something to me
along the lines of that,
even when you were looking for roles,
they just weren't really written for you,
and that's why you had to
start making them yourself.
- Yeah, and no one called
me, I didn't have directors,
like, I would love to work with
her, it just didn't happen.
Every once in a while
I would get the fortune
of working with someone I really
looked up to and respected,
but for the most part,
that phone did not ring.
So I was like, I'm gonna
build the telephone,
and call people with that telephone,
and make it ring for myself.
But really, it became so
much about creating jobs
for a lot of different people in the goal
of wanting to make fun things,
'cause you can't make anything alone.
- Yep, exactly.
- And I love what you're
doing with "Nikki Fre$H,"
and I've been listening
to all these radio shows
about how nurturing for so many
syndromes that gardening is,
and people did victory
gardens back in the day,
and I do think that you are
always ahead of the game
and on the pulse with your
gardening, and you are so cool,
and you are from obviously
musical, legendary family,
and you're married into that,
and oh my god, by the
way, your sister-in-law,
I mean, that's what really
also, we had already-
- That's what brought us together.
Cameron Diaz, again, not to name drop,
is your sister-in-law,
and my one of my oldest,
and I just, I love you, Nicole.
You are such a cool, fun,
hip, mellow, aware, with it.
(Nicole chuckling)
You are the complete package,
and I can't wait to
wrap my arms around you,
and get our beardies together.
- Same.
They don't have to social
distance, I feel like.
- I don't feel like.
I think, by the way, this one's
solo, and she needs Speedy.
So as soon as it's appropriate,
we're gonna get them together.
- Okay.
- Okay, perfect.
Thank you, Nicole.
- Great.
- "Nikki Fre$H."
- Love you.
- I love you so much.
All episodes of "Nikki Fre$h"
are streaming on Quibi,
and her new album, Unearthed,
is available right now.
(upbeat instrumental music)